-As wildfires
and an out-of-control pandemic
continue to rage,
the president and his party
are descending deeper
into lawless authoritarianism.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
Donald Trump and his allies
desperately want you to believe
that, for the last four years,
Joe Biden
has been the president.
For example, last week,
the Trump campaign
released an ad with the text...
I mean, he does live here,
but that's about it.
By the same token,
this is Ben Affleck's America
or Cue Card Wally's America.
-Seth, I would love to tell you
about my healthcare plan.
-No, no, Wally.
And, on "Meet the Press"
yesterday,
GOP Chairwoman Ronna McDaniel
had this to say
when asked about Trump's
coronavirus failures.
-You compare us to the rest
of the Western world,
and we have failed.
Is there any way to look at this
and compare to the Western world
and say that we've done better
than other countries?
-I will just tell you right now,
if Democrats were in charge,
if Joe Biden had his way --
Go look at his statements
in January,
when he said the president
was being xenophobic
-He's not the president.
-and hysterical
for closing the borders
to China.
-He's not the president.
-No, no no.
He was running for president
and he had the same data
and the same information.
So I think it's disgusting
to take a crisis in our country
and try and lay it
at the feet of the president.
-First of all, I'm not sure
Biden did have the same data
and information
as the sitting president.
With that said, Trump probably
never looked at that data,
so, maybe that's what she means?
"Joe Biden has access
to cable news and Twitter,
just like the president."
And I'm not sure
it is disgusting
to take a crisis in our country
and lay it at the feet
of the guy who's in charge
of our country.
What other options do we have?
Should we just leave
a negative review
on Chipotle's Yelp page?
That hardly seems fair.
Seriously, you guys
are the party
of personal responsibility,
except when the person
is Donald Trump.
On Friday, we recorded
1,200 new deaths in one day.
Canada recorded zero.
Yet, when she was asked
about Trump's failures,
McDaniel blamed the death toll,
nonsensically,
on increased testing.
-How do you account
for the fact that it's
the United States of America
that accounts
for 25% of the world's deaths?
-Well, we do have more testing.
-Wait, what?!
Do you think the tests
are killing people?
How deep are they
pushing those swabs?
We test people to see
if they're sick,
not to see if they're dead.
You know that, right?
Have you ever watched
an episode of "Law & Order"?
When the M.E. shows up,
it's to determine
cause of death, not,
"Are they going to be okay?"
Trump has catastrophically
mishandled the worst crisis
in this country
in over 100 years
and he's lied to the
American people about it,
as we learned last week from the
bombshell Woodward tapes.
But it's not just that
he's an incompetent liar.
He's also actively
making it worse.
Last night, he held his first
indoor rally in months
in Nevada, In violation of the
state's COVID restrictions.
There were lots of chanting
and very little
social distancing
and many refused
to wear masks at all.
If you were actively trying
to get people sick,
this is how you would do it.
The only way he could spread
the virus more efficiently is
to hold a rally
at a meatpacking plant
and charge one French kiss
for admission.
At his next rally,
there's gonna be one
Make America Great Again Kleenex
that everyone has to share.
[ As Trump ]
Just blow your nose
and pass it around.
[ Singsong ]
Trump fever!
We know these events
can seed outbreaks
because it's already happened.
After Trump's
Tulsa rally in June,
the local health director
said it was likely
the source of a surge
in cases there.
Even the current director of the
National Institutes of Health,
Francis Collins, who's normally
very mild-mannered,
had harsh words for how
irresponsible these events are.
-What do you think
when you see these images
of an event like this?
-It just deeply
puzzles me, Sanjay.
How did we get here?
Imagine you were an alien
who landed on planet Earth
and you saw that our planet
was afflicted
by an infectious disease
and that masks were an effective
way to prevent the spread.
And, yet, when you went around,
you saw some people
not wearing them
and some people wearing them
and you tried to figure out why
and it turned out
it was their political party.
And you would scratch
your head and think
this is just not
a planet that has
[ Laughing ]
much promise for the future.
-Well, I mean, at this point,
I'm guessing
most intergalactic ports
have travel advisories
warning aliens not
to come to Earth.
And what a terrible time
for an alien to land here,
if they were lookin'
for any kind of attention.
[ Robotically ]
I am Bylor from Grammax Seven.
What?!
Okay, good for you.
Just put on a [bleep] mask
while you're here, okay?
If an alien landed
on planet Earth right now,
they'd take one look around,
shift into reverse,
and hightail it outta here
like a family of tourists
who took a wrong turn
on vacation.
"There's a deadly virus
and the sky is orange?
You know what, kids?
Get back in the sponsorship.
I don't care!
You can pee
when we get to Venus!"
As controversial as this
may sound to Republicans,
the fact is Donald Trump
is currently the president
And he's overseen
an era of crisis
unprecedented in our lifetimes.
It's hard to watch
what's happening
in our country right now
and avoid the conclusion
that everything is broken --
rich ghouls are dismantling
the post office,
kids can't go to school,
there are massive lines
at food banks,
we're nearing
200,000 COVID deaths;
and, in the West,
millions of acres have burned,
the air itself
is a health hazard
and the sky is literally orange.
I mean, holy [bleep]
This looks like a scene
from "Total Recall."
No wonder Kuato's been all
over the TV lately.
I'm sorry, America's Kuato.
When Trump flies in
to tour the damage,
he should have the guitar guy
from "Mad Max: Fury Road"
strapped to the front
of Air Force One.
You know, the apocalyptic nature
of the Trump era
has really been on the nose,
in many ways,
but even I never thought we'd
have to lock ourselves inside
and wear face masks
while the sky turns blood-red.
I feel like I'm in a YA novel.
The only thing we're missing is
Forest Whitaker in a mech suit,
tellin' us we have
to find time crystals
to restore balance
to the universe.
[ As Whitaker ]
Schools are closed,
the sky is orange,
and Tom Brady is
on the Buccaneers.
We must reset the timeline.
The only upside of 2020 is
there's a good chance
the film adaptation will star
Jennifer Lawrence
and Timothee Chalamet
and we can all use
just a little --
just a little bit more Chalamet.
Also, imagine finally reemerging
from six months of quarantine,
only to be told you have
to go back inside
for a different thing.
"Oh, is it COVID surging again?"
Um, no.
It's not that.
It's -- Ooh!
How do we put this?
The sky is on fire.
More than 3 million acres have
burned in California, alone.
In Oregon, 40,000 people
have been evacuated
and half a million are
in potential danger zones.
And there is no doubt
that the frequency
and intensity of these
extreme weather events
have been supercharged
by climate change.
New research shows that the
Earth hasn't warmed this fast
in tens of millions of years.
L.A. County just set a new
record temperature of 121°.
That's insane.
Scientists and experts
have been clear
that what we're seeing right now
is the direct result
of climate change.
-We just had two unprecedented
heat waves back-to-back,
some of the hottest temperatures
ever experienced
in the Southwest
and in California,
both of them basically
unprecedented,
made worse by climate change.
And that really dries
out the foliage.
It dries out the brush.
It dries out the trees.
What that does is it adds energy
and heat to the atmosphere.
That dries out the brush.
It dries out the atmosphere.
It causes a moisture gap,
or moisture deficit,
in the atmosphere
and research shows that
that moisture deficit
can explain almost all
of the increase
in burned area since the 1970s.
-That's right,
climate change has produced
a moisture gap that's
making wildfires worse.
Of course, a moisture gap is
also what you call the distance
between Trump's lips
and a bottle of water.
[ As Trump ]
Damn you, water. C'mere.
Stop -- Stop playing
co coy, water.
You guys, we gotta get someone
to close the moisture gap.
Can we put Fauci on it,
to work on a solution?
Why?
What's he working on?
COVID, still?
Alright.
Six of the top 20
largest wildfires
in California's history have
all happened just this year
and, if we don't take
mass collective action
to address climate change now,
things are only gonna get worse.
-Unfortunately,
climate change is happening
right now in California
and we've been lengthening
the fire season
quite considerably
as we warm up the planet.
We know, because of research
from scientists,
that we have 500%
more risk for wildfires
during this climate-changed
world than we would have before
and that's because
it's really hot and dry
because we have had droughts.
And, of course, that drought,
which is caused
by climate change,
has led to a lot
of vegetation dying,
meaning there's a lot
of brush lying around
that can easily light up.
The fact is, climate change
is the real culprit
behind what
we're seeing right now.
-Should we expect
that trend to continue?
-Unfortunately, we should.
What scientists are telling us
is that we are entering
a period of mega fires.
-I love when scientists
say the hell with it
and give something
a simple-to-understand,
yet terrifying, name,
just so we might pay a little
bit of attention to it.
Most of the time,
scientists use jargon,
like "anthropogenic
climate change"
or "atmospheric aerosols,"
but, when they discover
something really bad,
they just give it a name
that makes you
[bleep] your pants.
"So, as you can see here,
rising heat combines
with wind turbulence
to form eddes of air
that create a vortex
of combustible gases
and hexapod invertebrates,
or what we in the science
community call...
We all laughed when Syfy
came out with "Sharknado,"
but, if they make another one,
I'm gonna be watching it
with a notepad.
Sharks can penetrate
cinder block.
Okay. Good to know.
Good to know.
So while a deadly pandemic
continued to grow
in at least 11 states,
with the nation's
top infectious disease expert
calling the situation
disturbing,
and historic wildfires scorched
millions of acres
across the West,
turning the sky orange
and making the air
a health hazard
for millions of Americans,
what was the president
of the United States doing?
He was watchin' hours
and hours of Fox News.
-I watch some of the...shows.
I watched Liz McDonald.
She's fantastic.
I watched Fox Business.
I watched Lou Dobbs last night,
Sean Hannity last night,
Tucker last night, Laura.
I watched "Fox & Friends"
in the morning.
You watch these shows,
you don't have to go
too far into the details.
They cover things that are --
It's really an amazing thing.
-My God, man, you just named
like six different
Fox News shows!
Were you stuck overnight
in an airport?
No one should watch that much
Fox News in one sitting.
That's like telling your doctor
you smoke once a day,
but you cram 50 cigarettes
in your mouth at once.
Also, can we go back
to this comment?
-You watch these shows,
you don't have to go
too far into the details.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
Heaven forbid we get caught up
in the details
on our news shows.
[ As Trump ]
You know what I like
about Hannity?
Never uses words that are
longer than one syllable.
Very easy to follow.
That's the president
of the United States,
bragging that,
as several states were on fire
and the death toll
from an out-of-control pandemic
neared 200,000,
he was sitting
in front of his TV,
watching Fox News,
like a grandpa whose Rascal
scooter ran out of batteries.
[ Gravelly voice ]
Someone push me
into the other room.
And, when he's not watching Fox,
he's on Fox, like on Saturday,
when he sat down
for an interview
with Jeanine Pirro,
where he threatened
to send federal forces
to put down protests
after the election,
falsely claimed shadowy figures
were behind civil unrest,
and celebrated extrajudicial
killings by state forces.
-Let's say there are threats.
They say that they're
gonna threaten riots,
if they lose on election night.
Assuming we get a winner
on election night.
What are you gonna do?
-We'll put 'em down
very quickly, if we do that.
-How are you gonna do that?
-We have the right to do that.
We have the power
to do that, if we want.
Look, it's called insurrection.
The suburbs is gonna be next.
-Yeah!
-Look, the suburbs, the people,
these same protesters --
but they're not protesters.
They're anarchists,
they're agitators,
-Who are they?
-and they're rioters.
-They're people that,
in many cases, are paid.
Now, we sent in
the U.S. Marshals
for the killer
and, in a short period of time,
they ended in a gunfight.
This guy was a violent criminal
-A lotta them out there.
-and the U.S. Marshals
killed him.
And I will tell you something.
That's the way it has to be.
There has to be retribution
when you have crime like this.
-I mean, just listen
to the words he's using --
retribution, agitators,
insurrection.
It's like fascist
magnetic poetry.
And also, no one
is destroying the suburbs.
What are you talkin' about?
The only thing
destroying the suburbs
is the proliferation
of Spencer's gifts
in our nation's malls,
poisoning our children's minds
with their sexy calendars!
As a general rule,
I wouldn't trust Jeanine Pirro
as a source of information
on anything,
since I'm pretty sure
her blood alcohol level
is like 99% white wine spritzer.
Her show on mute is still louder
than an F-15 taking off.
It's hard to watch this
and avoid the conclusion
that these ghouls want
a straight-up fascist state
where the government can put
down protests with violence
and seek extrajudicial
retribution against suspects.
Meanwhile, they don't care
if the country crumbles.
Large parts of the West
are on fire,
a deadly virus is
on the rise in 11 states,
and Americans are lining up
for hours at food banks.
And, if you're wondering
which of those crises
the president is currently
keeping an eye on,
don't worry,
he's closely monitoring...
-The...shows.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses
and they need your help.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
We love you.